britain's four-day celebration honoring
queen elizabeth is over and she says it
left her humbled and deeply touched the
queen appeared on the balcony of
buckingham palace one more time last
night this was a surprise everybody was
hoping she'd be able to rally and she
did look at the queen looking lovely in
green prince charles and his wife
camilla joined her along with prince
william and his family holly williams
reports on the last days of the platinum
jubilee party that had something for
just about everybody
[Music]
there aren't many 96 year olds who get a
pop concert staged in their honor
serenaded by alicia keys
and diana ross
[Music]
but this was a musical celebration of
queen elizabeth's 70-year reign a thank
you from the nation including her son
prince charles
your majesty
mommy
[Applause]
the queen was represented by three
generations of her family though she
stayed at home she's had mobility issues
in recent months
t
but she still managed to steal the show
never mind you would like a marmalade
sandwich
i always keep one for emergencies in a
video she made with another icon
paddington bear i keep mine in here the
eccentric british humor sent the crowd
wild
[Applause]
thank you
for everything
that's very kind
yesterday the queen's gold state coach
joined a carnival through central london
with a performance by ed sheeran
and watched by a misbehaving prince
louis
and around the country people came
together for street parties around
sixteen thousand community get-togethers
from a meet-and-greet with these corgis
prince and lily
they play the part of the queen's real
dogs on the tv series the crown
to rig dale street in east london
where they had a royal themed hat parade
and the queen made a two-dimensional
appearance it's like 70 years
you know that is have just been
steadfast and she made that promise to
serve her people and she's still doing
it now this lady told us she remembered
watching the queen's coronation as a
small child she's been the queen while
i've been alive for so many years yes
she's just been there all the time
and last night finally
another glimpse of the queen on the
balcony of buckingham palace
send her victorious happy and glorious
they sang
god save the queen
[Music]
the queen is now back home here inside
windsor castle she said in a statement
last night that while she didn't attend
all the events at her platinum jubilee
she remains committed to serving her
people to the best of her ability gail
nate tony
holly williams thank you she makes
everybody so proud they said it was a
celebration of hope of honor all
tributes to the queen but
it is worth going online to see the
memes of little louie
the way that he at one point he covers
his mother's mouth he makes it he gives
a raspberry in her face and she has that
look on her face that all mothers can
relate to and there's a very funny meme
online with how black mothers would
react to this like
we're gonna run to the bathroom right
quick we're gonna be right back we'll be
right back we're gonna have a little
conversation with little louie but he's
just being a little key when they clinch
their teeth they're like you've been a
funny girl right now exactly and then
smile and then smile like everything is
all right she is so loved unanimously
love very much so all right